[Music]
tomorrow night 15 000 cheering fans will
pack madison square garden in new york
city to witness a giant basketball
double header
in that cheering crowd sitting in row c
seat 11 will be a modest 77 year old man
those fans won't know that he made
possible the game they are watching
but you're going to meet him now
sanke coffee has brought him here
tonight all the way from lawrence kansas
dr james a naismith
the inventor of basketball
dr naismith how did you happen to invent
basketball
well mr heater was in the winter of 1891
when i was physical instructor at
springfield college in massachusetts we
had a real new england blizzard
for days the students couldn't go
outdoors so they began roughhousing in
the halls
we tried everything to keep them quiet
we tried playing a modified form of
football in the gymnasium
but they got bored with that
something had to be done
one day i had an idea i called the boys
to the gym
divided them up into teams of nine and
gave them an old soccer ball i showed
them two peach baskets i'd nailed up at
each end of the gym
i told them the idea was to throw the
ball into the opposing team's peach
basket
i blew a whistle and the first game of
basketball began and what rules did you
have for your new games dr neisman
well i didn't have enough and that's
where i made my big mistake
the boys began tackling kicking and
punching in the clinches
they ended up in a free-for-all in the
middle of the gym floor
before i could pull them apart one boy
was knocked out several of them had
black eyes and one had a dislocated
shoulder
it certainly was murder
well after that first match i was afraid
they'd kill each other but they kept
nagging me to let them play again so i
made up some more rules
the most important one was that there
should be no running with the ball
that stopped tackling and slugging
we tried out the game with those rules
and we didn't have one casualty we had a
fine clean sport
ten years later basketball was being
played all over the country
and in 1936 i saw it played for the
first time at the olympic games
and the whole thing started with a
couple of peach baskets i put up in a
little gym
48 years ago
i guess it just goes to show what you
can do if you have to indeed
[Applause]